dans le reste de l'actualité on va
parler du coc vide encore eh oui mais
cette fois en positif avec une
innovation voir une petite révolution en
indre et loire une entreprise vient de
mettre au point des gants qui protège
contre le virus à 98% l'high tech lytess
pardon spécialiste des tissus
intelligents n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai reportage de romans delville
après lé masque en tissu anti qu'ovide
vitesse se lance dans les gants virucide
la société cosmétotextile basée à
fondettes plutôt spécialisé dans les
vêtements intelligents type legging
minceur prend le tournant sanitaires ce
sont des gants double action qui vont
avoir dans un premier temps une action
déperlante qui va permettre au micro
gouttelettes de ne pas se fixer et puis
dans un second temps surtout d'avoir une
action virucide une une action qui va
agir sur la membrane extérieure des
virus et qui va permettre de détruire le
virus immédiatement et donc de se
protéger et de protéger les autres aussi
du virus les premières livraisons sont
arrivés avant noël de lusine maison de
monastir en tunisie l'idée en fait a été
lancé au printemps dernier testé dans un
laboratoire de microbiologie au royaume
uni la nouvelle vague de co vide en
europe pourrait bien faire s'envoler les
ventes pour aller faire ses courses pour
prendre les transports en commun mais
aussi les professionnels car tous les
professionnels qui vont livrer des colis
qui vont prêter un stylo pour la
signature on a également des demandes
sur les aides à la personne qu'il et
voilà les personnels de santé qui vont
au domicile et qui vont être amenés
aussi à toucher beaucoup de choses dans
l'univers des personnes malades pour pas
les contaminer davantage donc c'est
aussi un produit qui peut être utilisé
dans ce contexte là efficace à 98%
contre les coronavirus à l'achat lavable
les gants vie russie tout comme les
masque en tissu s'inscrivent aussi dans
l'objectif de la fin du tout jetable